[Applause]
[Music]
kathleen keenan's life
was all about fun and family but those
happier times
were brought to an abrupt end by covid
it was the manner of it
it was somebody saying your mom doesn't
count
kathleen tested positive for the virus
in hospital but was sent back to her
care home
in line with policy from the time you
know they were like
fodder on the infantry line and you know
just get rid of all of those because
we're not saving them because we we
haven't got enough resources and
time kathleen was one of 12 patients
with covid
discharged from walsall manor hospital
into care homes
a national push to free up beds started
on march the nineteenth on april the
second
care homes were told negative tests are
not required prior to transfers or
admissions
on april the 15th it was updated
introducing a policy of
testing all residents prior to admission
to care homes
but how many were discharged untested or
with covid
before the policy changed sky news has
contacted all nhs acute trusts in
england
from those who responded 6435 people
were discharged into a care home
between the 19th of march and the 15th
of april
of those 4 4210
weren't tested that's two-thirds of
discharged patients
and 623 of those who were tested
had a positive result during this period
the number of deaths in care homes was
peaking conrad chica
is a care provider in the yorkshire area
he refused to take covid patients from
hospital it is a disastrous policy to
bring
people in to a nursing or residential
setting
when somebody suffering with with
coronavirus
puts the safety of all the other
residents
at risk campaigners who've lost loved
ones to covert say our findings are
shocking
charlie williams's dad rex died in a
care home
patients flooded our care homes
and the result is thousands
and thousands of our care
of our families
across the country walsall healthcare
nhs trust offered condolences to
kathleen's family
and told us there weren't bed capacity
issues when kathleen was discharged
they say the care home was happy for her
to return
a department of health and social care
spokesperson said
we've been doing everything we can to
ensure care home residents and staff are
protected
at every stage we've been guided by the
latest scientific advice
regular testing for staff and residents
has now begun starting with homes for
over 65s and those with dementia
kathleen's family believes the discharge
policy cost
lives i can't do anything for my mom now
other than honor a memory
and you know ask for an apology for what
happened to her
because she deserved far better than she
got um but i don't want any other family
to be in the same situation
as we are this corner of the garden
reminds helen of her mum and why she's
fighting
to ensure others don't suffer her loss
laura bundock sky news
you